[موسيقى]
و النسخه الاحداث من هذه الطوافه هي طائره
النقل يو اتش وان واي ومروحيه اي اتش 1 زد
الهجوميه التي اثبتت جدارتها على ساحه
المعارك الحاليه ولديها اكبر عدد من
القدرات فيما يخص تشكيله الواسع من
الاسلحه التي يمكنها حملها كما انها تتميز
بقدره صمود عاليه في ساحه المعركه وايضا
قابله للصيانه وهاتان الطوافتان تمتلكان
خواص مشتركه بالنسبه ثمانين في المئه مما
يساعد على تقليل التكلفه اللوجستيه
[موسيقى]
وهناك الكثير من المعلومات التي بوسع هذه
الطائره ان تساعد في تشخيص شهادات الجنه
لدينا مختصون في الصيانه على متن المروحيه
بامكانهم الاستفاده من البيانات التي
ترسلها المروحيه من اجل المساعده في
التعرف واصلاح اي احتياجات من دون القيام
بالعمليات التقليديه التي تشمل مقاربه
التجربه ومحاوله التعرف على المشكله
[موسيقى]
ففي الطائرات التناظريه على سبيل المثال
سنرى تدهور في مستوى الاداء نبدا بعده
بازاله واستبدال المكونات بتسلسل معين
للتعرف على اي نشاط صيانه سيحل المشكله
اما طوافه اي اتش 1 زد وكذلك يو اتش وان
واي نظرا لانظمه الطيران الالكترونيه
المتكامله فلدينا القدره على استخراج
البيانات من الطائره والدقه في تحديد
الخطوات التي نقوم بها مما يقلل في الختام
التكلفه على الوحده العسكريه التي تعمل
فيها المروحيه
[موسيقى]